joining us to discuss some of the latest
developments now is dr tom frieden
uh former director of the cdc and
currently the ceo and president
of resolve to save lives initiative of
vital strategies dr frieden
good morning um on wednesday dr redfield
the director of the
the current director of the cdc said the
coming months will be quote among the
most difficult in the public health
history
of the nation as of this morning what is
your advice to people as we head into
the holiday season
right now we're seeing more cases in
more places than ever before
yesterday covid killed more people in
this country than
any other cause this is a time to double
down
on protection protocols that means
masking up
and celebrating as safely as possible
you talk about masking up and we keep
hearing that message
even with a vaccine coming uh pfizer and
modernist still awaiting fda approval
right now can you give us a sense
timeline wise when we may have that and
what that rollout is that follows
on the one hand the news about vaccines
is really encouraging
they seem to work better than anyone had
hoped
and they're coming faster than most of
us expected but they won't come soon
enough
most people will not be able to get
vaccine for many months
and that's why it's so important that
we're even more careful now so that
when vaccine is finally available all of
us are around to get it
current recommendations are the front
line healthcare workers are going to get
the first batch
then the elderly but take us through
how that process is going to take place
because there is not enough
in that first batch for everyone
the big picture here is you want vaccine
to be trusted
so that people will take it and that
means there needs to be complete
transparency about all of the data
the safety the effectiveness rates there
also needs to be
fairness to make sure it's fair and for
that
the committee that looks at that that's
an advisory committee
of the country's top experts in vaccines
and infectious diseases
said let's start phase 1a as it's called
with health care workers and people who
live in
nursing homes or other senior citizens
residences
because they've accounted for about 40
percent of all deaths
and health care workers are out there
protecting and caring for all of us
so we have an ethical responsibility to
put them at the front of the line also
if they get it there'll be fewer
healthcare workers to take care of us
and they may spread it to their home and
family and to other patients so
we're starting where it will do the most
benefit and dr fredon talk more about
the timeline i know we've talked about
this a lot but when you believe everyone
will
who wants a vaccine or needs a vaccine
will be vaccinated
it's going to be hard to say that
government has some very ambitious
optimistic plans
but the reality is that things can go
wrong it can be a bumpy road
the vaccine is difficult to produce and
mass producing it has never been done
before
already we saw pfizer reduce its
estimate from 100 million doses
to 50 million doses so i think it's
going to be many months before
all of us who want the vaccine can get
it but it does look like it's coming and
i have to tell you the data that's
coming out of the vaccine is
way better than we thought possible so i
certainly would get it the day
it's my turn as long as the fda approves
it which they're likely to do
this coming week and the data clearly
shows that it's safe and effective
you just said you would get it and the
problem right now is there's still a lot
of people who are saying that they're
not certain
that they would we've seen former
president obama and clinton and bush
have said they'll get it
on camera so people can see that it's
safe how
do you tell people what do you tell
people so that they can believe
in this vaccine
trust is really important and for trust
complete transparency is crucial
we have to be clear about what we know
what we don't know
how we know it how we're going to find
out more and so we have to be honest and
say
listen tens of thousands of people have
gotten this vaccine and there hasn't
been a single
serious bad reaction that doesn't mean
that when hundreds of thousands or
millions of people get it
there might not be very rare bad
reactions and we have to track for that
and be very open about it but one of the
things that's really clear
is that convenience is really important
and when there is enough vaccine
making it easy for people to get the
vaccine particularly because
the vaccines that are being authorized
first are going to require two doses
three or four weeks apart
that's a big challenge making it easy
for people making the
healthy thing the default value the
easier thing to do whether that's
at your doctor's office or at a local
pharmacy or for nursing home residents
where you're living that's going to be
key to success
a lot of people talking about that polio
vaccine way back in the 60s if they
remember in those long lines
dr tom frieden thank you